Coffee on a Tuesday and Vlog,
43.
Minimalism is everywhere.
It's a style in which the simplest and
view as elements are used to create the
maximum effect and you can find
minimalism and almost every art form or
kind of media in the visual arts and
music and literature.
You can find it in architecture and
expensive food,
but most importantly,
I think for the current age,
you see it as defining trends in
advertising and design.
The influence here is in good part
Japanese where Zen Buddhist concepts of
simplicity inform living spaces and ways
of life and not only for its aesthetics,
but also as a moral imperative to
respect the quintessence of thing.
No filmmaker,
for example,
did a better job of capturing this.
Then Yasuhiro,
whose films you should watch immediately
after this video is over.
Of course,
camera always placed low to the ground.
Ozu films have a two dimensional quality
exhibiting what is essentially an
organization of geometric shapes.
I never forget the film frame itself is
directing.
This for me is the key of minimalism.
It's a movement of organized geometry.
The relationships of shapes inside what
is essentially just a bunch of
rectangles,
the TB screen,
the computer screen,
the film frame,
the Youtube player,
the billboard,
the street sign,
or the page.
A more recent influence is the Dutch
dish style movement or neoplastic system
as Pete Mondrian,
whose paintings you will most certainly
recognize said it is possible that
through horizontal and vertical lines
constructed with awareness but not with
calculation led by high intuition and
brought to harmony and rhythm,
that these basic forms of beauty
supplemented if necessary by other
direct lines or curves can become a work
of art.
As strong as it is true and it's true,
the geometrical organization is one of
intuition influenced perhaps by symmetry
and weight in photography by the rule of
thirds,
but finally achieved by a feeling.
This feels right,
comfortable balance.
Take my end screen.
For example,
I must've spent and hour making my newt
millimeter changes to the elements that
you see here,
which when paired down look like this,
three rectangles in a circle,
inside a larger rectangle trying to
achieve a kind of harmony between the
distances and empty blue space.
Maybe it was an hour wasted or maybe we
are more attracted to pieces of design
that work in the minimal sense.
Maybe in the full appraisal that you
take of my work,
the end screen design,
the framing,
the text,
the pictures reinforce or intensify the
reaction you have to the content.
The rise of minimalism is symptomatic of
a chaotic culture,
bombarded with information.
The organizational impulse is amplified
and we're drawn to messages or products
that help us to assemble disparate data
into a coherent whole.
So instead of this,
we want this and instead of these we use
this,
life is marked with contradictory,
but balancing trends.
Tendencies that aim in their way to
harmonize the of maternity minimalism is
a reminder and a welcome one that in a
fog of appointments and facebook
notifications and different types of
shampoo and homework and real work that
you can breathe
right.